your physical presence speaks louder
than you think
we're visual okay there's a reason why
our eyes are in the front of our face
okay we've got that telescopic vision
herbivores animals that get eaten for
example have their eyes on the side of
their head so they have as much vision
as possible to see the predators coming
predators have their eyes on the front
of their head so they can
have that depth perception that's why
humans are built that way with our eyes
in our front
we have to have physical presence we
have to have prowess
okay most guys out there i'm just going
to be honest with you most guys out
there
and i'm glad that the gyms are open and
when i see guys at the gym it's it's
mostly younger men
in there doing the work lifting weights
and they're doing the proper exercises
like dead lifts
and throwing around some heavy [ __ ] and
i'm really pleased to see that
but most of the guys out there i'll be
honest with you they're walking around
with
female breast you know material like
they like they literally have breasts
okay because because the estrogen levels
in their body are so high
because of what they consume and what
they put in and on their body
and people laugh when i say stuff like
this they think oh you're going
overboard rich why did you have this dr
anthony jayon from estrogen
s regeneration talking about all that
stuff that's that's
you know that's a little much go read
the book you know there's a reason why i
bring these guests on
if you didn't see that episode it was on
playing to win i don't know what the
number was it's somewhere around 15 but
dr anthony
uh j uh esther generation was a book go
watch it
there's a lot of guys out there that
don't look like men
there's a lot of men out there that
come off as weak soy boys and that's not
acceptable
you have to have a strong physical
masculine presence if you want to be
respected by
peers of men and be desired by women
there's no way around it you have to
signal that and not everybody can do
that i get that you know the big
argument that a lot of the black pillar
guys are
well it's impossible not everybody can
be like fit and whiskey
you know it's like fine you're either
going to find a way to make it happen
you know to reach your genetic potential
or you're going to find excuses as to
why
you can't reach your genetic potential
oh i'm not tall enough
i don't have the right bone structure
blah blah blah okay they got more
stories than walt disney
manufactured in their head and a problem
for every solution that you offer
cut those people out get rid of them the
guys that are listening to this right
now that are not in their head going
yeah he's probably right i should
probably consider that because when i
get out of the shower and i look down i
can't see my johnson because i'm all
belly fat
but i'm 22. and i see this picture rich
here on the internet and he's 47 and
he's
jack juiciest af it's because i've done
the work
i look like this in my twenties i've
i've not changed over the years
okay it's just a matter of you getting
out there
and having that physical presence the
strength and
reaching your genetic potential again
men in general have the burden of
performance women don't they just have
to show up and look pretty
they don't have any obligation beyond
that really uh super chat from elliot
says great content as always thanks for
the great work thank you for the
donation brother
um conch just posted the estrogenics
interview in the youtube chat so if
you're not
watching this on youtube i'm gonna copy
and paste it again if you came in late
get your ass over there please watch
this on youtube uh
thanks conk for that uh just open that
up in another window you can watch that
afterwards
if you're listening to this on podcast
because i know some of you guys listen
this on itunes stitcher spotify you know
all that stuff
um just search on my channel un under
the playlist playing the win for dr
anthony j
and watch that get your ass in gear
okay at the end of the day you have work
to do you have you have work to do
if you're not the strongest best version
of yourself
i know elliot hulse gets flocked from
time to time because of what he does
and some of the things that he's
preaching about but at the end of the
day
he made a life and a business you know
for himself um
talking about becoming stronger he's a
strong man right get your ass out there
and develop physical masculine
traits your physical appearance speaks
louder than you think people notice when
you walk into a room
when you're jacked people don't notice
when you walk in as a scrawny loser
they see you as a scrawny loser i'm not
saying you're all gonna become you know
jacked and juicy in the next year but
start doing some work
eating properly getting your rest done
i'm not ever gonna do videos on this
channel about
you know my my routine how i work out
what my protocols are because it's all
out there on everybody else's channel
there's
so much free material out there and i
learned it all myself and
at the end of the day you guys know what
needs to be done move more
lift heavy [ __ ] eat better sleep more
it's not magic okay there's no magic
formula
you